so dolly parton is just a country singer
i thought
yeah and then and then you basically
broke down
her whole life she's been married
forever yup
nobody knows anything about her husband
really and
she's actually like a savage
businesswoman who
plays kind of dumb when
she's in public she's all right
when everybody else is playing checkers
she's so good
she's so she couldn't beat me in chess
but go ahead she's so good
so first of all what you need to know
about dolly partner is she was born in
extreme poverty
she was one of 12 kids born in a
one-bedroom log
cabin in the mountains of tennessee and
um and she grew up without electricity
think about 12 kids in a one-bedroom
log cabin in tennessee sounds like they
had a lot of fun
and when she moved to nashville she by
the way she met her husband the first
day she moved to nashville
at a laundromat and um
basically she was trying to be this
country singer country star
and they were like you're very rough
around the edges because she came from
like a really really poor
uh place and i watched this documentary
and they were saying like she would use
language that was very crude that like
ladies didn't use um but they liked her
because
it gave her character she kind of played
dumb she was honest
yeah and um and they told her dolly
she was like oh by the way i'm going to
get married and they're like no you're
not
you have this like sex appeal you're
going to play into this image
basically your career is going to be
over if you get married and
like men can't like you know fantasize
like you're single you have sex appeal
whatever
and she was like okay and then she
didn't tell anybody
they got secretly married at the
courthouse and a year later she went
back and they were like oh no you can't
get married like whatever
and she's like by the way i've been
married for a year and you didn't know
and i have a great career so what's your
point
she she does things like that she um
you know a lot of people are like they
want to
use stereotypes and make fun of her um
so they're like oh well like if they
want to make fun
of the fact that she has a lot of
plastic surgery or she has like really
big fake boobs or whatever
and she and when they make a joke about
it they'll be like
uh oh well you're fake or whatever and
she'll say
i may be fake but i'm real in all the
like places that matter
and she'll kind of she's already
expecting it and she
she um like it tosses it back to them
and the whole point is like you can only
feel shame
if you allow them to shame you she
doesn't care
is it fair to say that most famous
successful people did not get lucky and
they're actually
very very intelligent know exactly what
they're doing
yes like she's kanye west
is probably much more intelligent than
people give him credit for
i think some people get lucky but
then it catches up to them and they fall
into obscurity because they're not
willing to
be strategic how much money do we think
dolly parton makes do we know
oh i'm i'm not i'm not sure
but like like do we think that he's
worth 100 mil
10 million a billion probably closer to
100 million
yeah if i had to guess she um she's
actually really philanthropic
uh she because her dad didn't know how
to read
um she started an organization called
the imagination library in 1995.
today her program spans five countries
five countries and gifts over one
million free books each month to kids
around the world
and today she's donated more than 140
million books
wow 140 million books yeah that's wild
to kids all around the world all right
what'd you learn from her um
i learned a lot by the way if you want
to read the dossiers you can go to
readtheprofile.com readtheprofile.com so
okay so here's a fun one you probably
didn't know
i learned to try me okay so
she you know at the time was kind of
building her career she was still
relatively young
and imagine your dolly parton
and you have this song that you wrote
that you sang called
i will always love you and in the 70s
elvis presley wanted to
record her song but his manager
wanted half the publishing rates and she
said no
that's not fair i wrote it i sing it
it's my song and she wouldn't budge on
the position so
they couldn't come to terms and she said
no
and people were like wow like my god
she's a woman she should be honored that
elvis presley wants to record her song
and here's what she said she said i
never thought of it as being about being
a man or a woman
i thought of about it as being an artist
and a writer and a person of strong will
so she just like wasn't willing to budge
on this one
thing and she said it broke my heart to
say no but i was willing to suffer that
temporary disappointment and heartache
than to live with something that i knew
was wrong um so yeah so then
whitney houston as we know i will always
love you
uh became famous that that became her
song she became famous with that song
uh and dolly says um i'm happy that
you know she became that would people
associate that song with her
as long as um as long as i'm still
making the money so as long as dolly
parton's getting paid she don't get who
gets the credit
yeah i mean she's focused on the right
thing for them because when you hear
that song you think of uh whitney
houston not
uh dolly parker the dolly parton the
savage is the one who actually made it
i love it